(orchestral music)
- This is what I hope to see when I die.
- I mean, I don't know who
doesn't love fried chicken.
- If you wanna seduce me,
just offer me fried chicken.
And I'm (snaps) like that.
(orchestral music)
- Everyone's gonna win today
because it's fried chicken.
- Except like your cholesterol
levels and your arteries.
- This tastes like some off brand chicken.
- It's good.
- It's buttery.
- This one necessarily
doesn't have that much
of a crunch to it.
- It's dark meat, it's fatty, it's rich,
it's luxurious.
- That was pretty good,
I'd give it like an eight
out of 10.
- I like really, really crispy chicken,
so I'd give it a five.
- Oh this smells good.
- Like the outside isn't really that oily,
but once you go inside,
it's like a vat of oil.
- The chicken is a
little dry for my taste.
- Oh, it's so spicy.
- It feels like the skin
and the chicken are two
different things, and I don't like that.
- I feel like this is--
- I think it might be Popeyes.
It's got that nice little Popeyes flavor.
- Five out of ten, would not eat again
if these weren't in front of me.
- Already 100% sure this is KFC.
- You know your chicken.
- Oh, I just got a huge bite of grease.
- This one made my spit
really stick to the chicken
as I pulled away from it.
- I dig this one.
This is probably first
place for me right now.
- I don't know, this is pretty good,
but I don't think it's as
good as Roscoe's or Louisiana.
- No.
- This tastes to me like
the most processed so far.
- It's mostly breading.
- You know what, I'm just
gonna take another bite
because I might not eat dinner tonight.
- (muffled speaking)
- Did you say "take me to church?"
- I like this one.
- This one is very, very greasy.
This came like straight from the fire.
- I hope I don't get diarrhea. (laughs)
- This is definitely the
best wing I've had so far.
- It's too wet.
- Yeah, it's really wet.
I don't like it.
- I don't know what this
brand is, but I'm not...
Maybe this was the church one.
- That's too much...
It's not even chicken
anymore, it's just fried skin.
You have some skin on your lip.
(laughs)
- Smell that.
- (exhales excitedly)
- I like the skin.
- Mhm.
- Mm, that flavor, damn!
- This one was like the perfect dessert
to the rest of these.
- Look at how much chicken as well.
Like this came from an
animal, you can tell.
- This one is seasoned
really, really well.
(muffled speaking)
- Winner winner, chicken dinner.
Boom!
- Boom!
- That one.
- Louisiana, Popeyes, KFC,
Church's, Roscoe's.
- Roscoe's, Popeyes, KFC, Church's,
Louisiana.
(screaming excitedly)
- [Both] We got it right!?
- We got it all right?
- [Both] Yeah!
- Boys, we're boys!
We're boys who like chicken!
Boys, we're boys,
who like (bleep) fried chicken!
Pick the chicken up, take a big bite,
let it down to the floor,
and have a good night, woo!